>> Announcer: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Hayden: We still have a lot
to learn and a lot to improve.
So I'm going to say this
is a call to action,
and if you have suggestions
on how we can improve the Library's
visitor experience for everyone,
please contact Travis
[laughter] and all of us.
He is our official person that
makes sure that accessibility stays
in the forefront of all of our
planning and all of our experiences.
Thank you, Travis.
Now I want to introduce our
amazing lineup of speakers we have
with us today, and these are
people who are making it happen.
Congressman Representative
Kevin Yoder
and Congressman Mark
Takano are the co-chairs
of the Congressional Deaf Caucus,
and we appreciate their time
and are honored to have them
here with us this afternoon,
and then the esteemed President
of Gallaudet University,
Miss Bobbie Cordano, who will
present to us information
about the state of deaf education
and the impact that EDA has had
on her life, and then she will
be followed by TEDx presenter,
August Shitama, on
his passion for books
and what they have
meant for his life.
I know you will enjoy the
presentations, and I just want
to thank you for being part
of this event and helping all
of us make sure that we
provide access for everyone.
So remember, we can clap like this.
[Laughter] Travis.
>> Painter: Well, good afternoon.
It's my honor to join this
esteemed panel and others
to help celebrate the 27th
anniversary of the passage
of the American with
Disabilities Act,
and I appreciate Dr. Hayden's
opening remarks and her allowing us
to have this event in this
beautiful, historic facility
that she maintains for
Americans to continue to enjoy
and to celebrate many
historic events.
Today is one of those chapters in
the great legacy of our country.
I want to thank all of you
for your commitment to working
for disabled Americans, especially
those in the deaf community,
in Congress, in Gallaudet
and the rest
of academia, and the private sector.
I'm proud to join all of you
in celebrating the Americans
with Disabilities Act today.
As we know, our nation was founded
on the principle that all people,
men, women, are created equal.
The ADA is a landmark piece
of legislation that embodied
that principle with its impact
making ripple effects throughout our
nation still today benefiting
countless disabled Americans.
It has helped open up doors,
both literally and figuratively,
to employment and services for many
people with disabilities and ensured
that those with disabilities
are afforded equal access
to government services
and public accommodations.
It's hard to think of our
country without the ADA.
It's hard to think of
America before that period
and why that was ever the case.
The ADA helped implement,
for example,
in the deaf community
telecommunications relay services,
making sure the deaf,
hard of hearing,
can have full access
to telephone networks.
These reforms were important steps
towards making sure that no one
in America gets left behind and
everyone has equal opportunities.
Now, I'm a Kansan, and Kansas has
a very special role in history
when it comes to the ADA.
That connection continues
today with the legacy left
by a great statesman
known as Senator Bob Dole,
who just recently had his
94th birthday, by the way.
He was and still is one
of biggest advocates
for the disability community,
inspiring myself and others
to continue to carry the
baton and his legacy forward.
He had such a special personal
story because as someone
with a disability stemming
from injuries sustained
in combat during World War II, he
was able to use his perspective
to help fight for others,
to help fight for all of us.
He was instrumental in the passage
of the ADA, and he viewed it as one
of his proudest moments, and long
after Senator Dole and others,
we've all passed in politics
his legacy, the ADA will pass
on from generation to generation.
He had a lot of proud moments.
He did a lot of things,
but saying it was one
of his proudest says a lot
considering his career.
So his legacy is an inspiration to
me and many of our fellow Kansans.
In my service in Congress, I
represent the Kansas School
for the Deaf in Olathe, Kansas.
I have had a great opportunity to
work with many of the students,
teachers, and community members
who make up my constituents
and who are a very important
part of our community,
and so what Senator Dole laid
forward is what I'm working
to fight for-to fight
for disability rights,
and I think the Senator would agree
there's still more to be done.
The difficult reality is that
in spite of the progress made
through the ADA, around
seven in ten deaf people
in the U.S. are unemployed
or under employed.
We have a lot of work to do.
This means that there are
33 million deaf people
who can't make enough money
to support themselves.
This is just one symptom that
shows that our work is not done
and there are clearly still barriers
between deaf people and quality jobs
and full involvement in society.
We've attempted to partner with many
employers throughout the country
to help them build
opportunities for employment.
Just a few months ago there was an
event we had at the Kansas School
for the Deaf with Uber, and they
were showing they have specific
programs set up to help the deaf
community become Uber drivers,
for example.
So technology is also helping
us solve this problem along
with government policy, but
in recognition of the need
to keep advocating for
the deaf community,
that was what led Congressman
Takano, my good friend
from California, and I to help form
and build the Congressional
Deaf Caucus.
We've been joined by 18
other members of Congress
who are all dedicated to advocating
on behalf of deaf Americans.
The Congressional Deaf
Caucus recognized
that the ADA was not the finish
line in disability rights,
but rather one step as part of
an effort that needs to continue.
Now I also have another role in that
when I was first came to Congress,
I was honored to be appointed
by the Speaker of the House
to the Gallaudet Board of Trustees,
and I am a proud Kansas Jayhawk.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not switching allegiances, but
I'm also a proud Gallaudet Bison,
and we're very proud of the
university here in Washington, DC,
and it's helped me create a
connection between the Kansas School
for the Deaf as folks
graduate high school
in helping them understand the
value of Gallaudet University,
as well as my colleagues
who in Congress may not know what
Gallaudet University is doing
in its powerful legacy
here in Washington.
It's the only university in the
world specifically designed for deaf
and hard of hearing students,
and I am glad to be a part
of this unique and
vital institution.
It has been a privilege to serve
the university and learn more
about the deaf community
and the issues it faces,
and President Cordano is leading an
outstanding school, and I'm working
to make sure that Gallaudet
has the resources it needs-
[Applause] All right, there we go.
I'm working to make sure that
Gallaudet has the resources it needs
to continue educating deaf students,
and we were just discussing
that most recently the
Appropriations Committee approved a
bill that included a
$6.7 million increase
for Gallaudet University
in the coming year.
In these very divided times we live
in, it's hard to turn on the news
without wanting to throw
your TV out the window.
People are angry at one another.
Gallaudet University is a
unifier in this Congress,
and to see a bipartisan
effort to increase support
in a significant amount
to me tells us
that there's still
hope for civility.
There's still hope
for bipartisanship,
and the issue of support at
Gallaudet University is one
of those great areas
we can come together,
and we know that those dollars,
if we can eventually get it signed
into law, will be served
and utilized very well
to help more students
fulfill their dreams.
So, in conclusion, as we mark the
27th anniversary of the Americans
with Disabilities Act, I hope we can
both celebrate the accomplishments
that have been made as well as roll
up our sleeves to continue the work
that still needs to be done.
I want to say thank you to
everyone here who has contributed
to the fight for the rights
of the disabled Americans
and for the deaf community
in particular, and I am proud
to join you in this
effort as we work
to preserve the legacies of ADA.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Painter: Thank you so
much, Congressman Yoder,
for your contributions and for
coming today and updating us
on a lot of the legislation
that's pending
and what there is more to do.
So thank you so much.
I would like to welcome
the other co-chair
of the Congressional Deaf
Caucus, Representative Takano.
[Applause]
>> Takano: Thank you.
Thank you.
Good afternoon and thank you.
Thank you for being here and thank
you to the Library of Congress
for inviting me to
this wonderful event.
Dr. Hayden, it's always wonderful
and a pleasure to see you.
I am truly grateful for
the work that you do,
and I promise to return
all of the overdue books
that I still owe to the library.
[Laugher] This week we celebrate the
27th anniversary of the Americans
with Disability Act, which
is a perfect time to reflect
on the contributions made
by so many deaf and hard
of hearing Americans
throughout American history.
From serving in the peace corps to
working in the federal government
to becoming teachers,
lawyers, and doctors,
deaf Americans have contributed to
the cultural and economic strength
of this nation, and your
influence is only growing.
I personally look forward to the day
that we see the first deaf
person elected to Congress,
and maybe it will be someone
who is in this room today.
[Applause] My Riverside
California district is home to one
of two California schools
for the deaf,
and that means I have the
honor of representing a large
and important deaf and
hard of hearing population.
When I came to Congress in
2013, I was shocked to see
that there was very
little representation
for the deaf community.
I decided to do something about it,
and I joined with Congressman
Kevin Yoder from Kansas,
who we just heard from, to launch
the Congressional Deaf Caucus.
It is a bipartisan group of
25 members who are advocating
for the deaf community, and new
members are joining every year.
The Caucus is dedicated to
bridging the communication divide
between members of Congress
and their deaf and hard
of hearing constituents, and we
focus on empowering deaf and hard
of hearing individuals to engage
with their members of Congress
because our country
is built on the idea
that every person deserves
fair representation.
So my office has taken the lead in
expanding internship opportunities
for deaf and hard of hearing
individuals on Capitol Hill.
To date my office has
hosted seven deaf interns
from Gallaudet University
[applause]-thank
you-including Catherine.
Catherine, would you
raise your hand?
And she's here with me today,
and I can say with sincerity,
and Catherine has just
taught me to sign this,
they have been amazing
interns, amazing interns.
[Applause] I still remember
Gallaudet, but I don't remember how
to do the university part.
It's like-this two here.
So it's half circle like this.
Gallaudet, half circle like that.
There you go.
Go Buffalo, or is it bison?
Go Bison. [Laughter] How
do you do bison, Catherine?
This, like this.
That's bison.
All right, thank you.
Building a strong coalition
of advocates for deaf and hard
of hearing individuals is
critical to making progress
on some key issues including
your right to serve your country.
A few years ago I introduced a Keith
Nolan Air Force Demonstration Act,
which would create a demonstration
program in the Air Force for 15
to 20 deaf and hard of
hearing individuals.
It was named after a young
man who has been fighting
for the deaf community's
ability to serve.
Keith Nolan's life goal is
to be a military officer.
He enrolled in and completed the
first two levels of Army ROTC
at the UCLA Cal State Northridge
program, but he was not allowed
to continue due to the
Department of Defense rules
that exclude individuals who
are deaf or hard of hearing.
He excelled in the ROTC program.
Keith is entirely capable
of serving.
The more people we have in
Congress who will stand up for Keith
and for others like
him who want to serve,
the better chance we will have of
expanding opportunities for the deaf
and hard of hearing community.
Now as I conclude my remarks
today I want to recognize some
of the transformative
work being done here
in Washington, DC but
not in Congress.
Now Gallaudet University is just
two miles from Capitol Hill,
and it was founded
during the Civil War
through a Congressional charter
signed by President Lincoln
to provide higher education
to deaf people.
It is the only liberal arts
university in the world,
in the world, that caters to deaf,
hard of hearing, and
deaf/blind students.
Not only does Gallaudet
provide a top notch education
for its students, it also
conducts ground breaking research
on language acquisition
and bilingual education.
As an aside, I learned on a visit
to the Riverside School for the Deaf
that an 18-month-old child has
a larger active vocabulary,
a greater ability to
communicate than a hearing child.
There is so much the general
public does not know or understand
about deaf and the hard
of hearing community,
and we need to work
together to change that.
I want to take a moment to
recognize a special guest
who has already been mentioned,
but I wanted to just give
another shout out to her.
We have her here today, and she's
going to speak in just a moment.
I want to say my own praises to
Gallaudet President Roberta Cordano,
who is the first deaf woman to lead
the school in its 152-year history.
What an amazing thing that is.
President Cordano, you are a
role model, not just for the deaf
and hard of hearing
community, but for every person
who has ever been told that
they can't do something
because of who they are.
It is an honor to be with
all of you this afternoon.
Thank you again for
inviting me to participate.
Thank you to the Library of
Congress and Dr. Hayden for the work
that you all do to ensure that
our history is fully accessible
to all Americans.
My promise to you is that
I will continue to work
with Congressman Yoder, the
Congressional Deaf Caucus,
and all members of Congress
to ensure that deaf and hard
of hearing people have
a place on Capitol Hill.
Thank you and good afternoon.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Painter: Thank you so much.
We have done an internship here
at the library as well and tried
to model it after Takano's,
Representative Takano's
internship program.
So we definitely thank him for
that as well, and now everyone
in their speech so far has
mentioned, President Cordano.
So now it is an honor to
welcome her to the podium.
[ Applause ]
>> Cordano: Hello, everyone.
Just checking on the microphone
to make sure we have
access to [inaudible].
First, I want to thank Dr.
Hayden for the very warm welcome
and my opportunity
to meet her today.
I agreed with her that there are so
many possibilities for partnerships
between Gallaudet and
the Library of Congress.
Secondly is Representative
Yoder, and many of you know he is
on the Board of Gallaudet
Trustees and a great supporter
of the university in terms
of our federal appropriations
that we receive yearly
from Congress.
We very much appreciate his support.
We do have three public
trustees on the Board
of Trustees at Gallaudet University.
We have Representative Butterfield,
Senator Butterfield, and also,
of course, Representative
Takano and Representative Yoder.
On the Senate side, we
have a Senator from Ohio,
which is Senator Brown, representing
that Congress representative
on the Board.
These folks are important allies to
us and the deaf community as well.
So I want to thank the three
of you for your support
of our community and for Gallaudet.
I'm truly honored to be here as
President of Gallaudet University
in the Library of Congress.
So the first question I have is
how many of you have a Library
of Congress reading card?
Let me see a show of hands.
Looks like three or four, maybe
five, six of you, seven, eight.
Well, let me say, if you
don't have a reading card,
I strongly suggest you come.
There's a building right across
the street where you go in.
You can sign up, get your
picture taken, and you get one
of these Library of
Congress reading cards.
So you can come into the reading
room right here in the Library
of Congress, and it's a wonderful
way to spend an afternoon
on a weekend or an early
morning, just to come and sit
and research and do some reading.
It's one of my favorite
things to do here in DC.
I'd encourage you all
to go over there
and get one of those reading cards.
It's probably the best thing you
can get here in this city and one
of the best things to do.
I do want to thank the
Library of Congress
for recognizing this
27th anniversary
of the Americans with
Disabilities Act.
We're here today to celebrate
that momentous occasion,
and also it's important for all
of us to understand some context
and what's happened in the years
since the passage of the ADA,
the support that we've
received, and our civil rights
and freedom associated with that.
This is first the 200th year of deaf
education here in the United States.
It was two hundred years ago at
the American School for the Deaf,
of which, of course there are
pictures up here in this room,
that deaf education began
here in the United States,
and it's important because
it's the first time in history
that a school was founded
on this notion
that visual language was very
important in the instruction
of deaf children, and the School
for the Deaf using
American sign language
to teach deaf children is a
methodology that was first learned
and then brought over from France.
We have a 200-year history
that we draw upon today.
If it wasn't for that event 200
years ago that led to the founding
of a number of schools for the
deaf throughout the United States,
those schools have since
produced, as you all know,
high school graduates, and it
was the beginning of the makings
of a middle class of deaf
people here in America.
The son of Thomas Gallaudet,
who founded, of course,
the American School for the Deaf,
came to realize there
were opportunities
in providing deaf people,
opportunities to get a college
education, and he worked
and then came to the DC area
to found the Columbia School
for the Deaf and Deaf Mute.
There was an elementary
school here in the area.
It was decided that they would begin
a university, and with the help
of Amos Kendell went on to found and
chartered through Congress signed
by Abraham Lincoln, the very
first and, as was mentioned
by Congressman Takano, the first and
continues to be the only university
in the world that provides direct
instruction to deaf individuals
through American sign language.
You know that experience continues
to be the only one like it
in the world, and that's what
makes this state even more special
and unique.
It is for all of us a reminder
of our need to continue
to protect the language of our
community, and that is the right
that is protected by the ADA,
the ability to communicate
through this language
and to do so effectively.
It's by no accident that Gallaudet
was part of the passage of the ADA.
If you remember, here in
the halls of Congress,
it was at that time the ADA
was being discussed that DPN,
Deaf President Now protests began.
Many of you in this room
were part of the DPN protest.
Some of you were.
I see here today.
There's a part of an
alumni community
that also supported
the Deaf President Now.
So there were seven what we call
ducks who were alumni supporters
of the Deaf President Now protest.
So it was that protest that
really woke up Congress
and drew the attention on
Gallaudet and deaf people's fight
for civil rights and all that
came with this and then led
to the passage of the Americans with
Disabilities Act, in a large part
because of the fire that was fueled
as a result of Deaf President Now.
Had it not been for DPN, I
think everyone would tell you
that the ADA would have never
passed, but DPN provided the energy,
the motivation, and the hope the
people could see, the deaf people,
the disabled wanted to be able to
be part of a civic life around them,
and that hope was made
possible through the ADA, and,
again it represented the hope of the
rights of people with disabilities
to be able to participate
fully in the civic life.
The ADA is not just about access.
It's about the right to
participate in community life.
You know, we sometimes
forget that language.
It's about our right to be members
of our community, to have access
to learning, to employment, to be
able to connect and participate
in community activities
and engagement and events,
to be able to go to movie
theaters, to be able to go
to theatrical productions, all
allowing for civic participation
in community life here
in this country.
I wanted to go back
to something here.
As I mentioned, you know,
it's the 200-year anniversary
of deaf education here
in the United States.
We're also celebrating
something else.
It's now, I believe, 58 years ago
that American sign language was
discovered to be a full language.
That discovery was made
at Gallaudet University.
It was the first time in
the history of the world
that sign language was
actually seen to be commiserate
to any other language that was
used, be it English, French, German,
Spanish, that American sign
language was given the same prestige
and recognition.
It was just 60 years ago that this
was verified, rather 57 years ago,
that this was verified to be the
case, and that is significant
in our understanding that
American sign language is still
in its infancy.
ADA is 27 years old.
American sign language is
only 57 years old in terms
of its recognition officially as a
language, and if we go from there
and understand that
from that understanding
that there is an official language,
there must be a culture, literature,
a form of arts that's
very unique and specific
to an individual language, and
that was as well proven to be true
as we began to recognize
books created by deaf people
and that spoke to Americans
of heritage and that
if you foster a language and an
art, then students came together
to verify one other
thing, and that is the fact
that they have civil rights,
that we have civil rights,
and that civil right mindset
has allowed us to participate
in a movement that's
far bigger than our own.
Minority rights in a country like
this has significant meaning.
Understanding that we
may be a small community,
we're a part of a larger
community and how is it
that we can get the
representation that we need
within that larger majority
culture, and then, of course,
those questions led to the
Deaf President Now protest
and another protest
which occurred in 2006.
I looked at that protest as
being a very significant one
for different reasons than
just being about this election
of a president, but it was instead
a way for the community at Gallaudet
to be able to express its right to
self determination and the rights
to be able to be part of a
process, to be engaged in a process,
the right to be included
in a process is what
that protest recommended.
It happened to be about the
selection of a president,
but it really was about the
right to be a part of the process
which creates self determination
and another part of being part
of a free country and a democracy
that allows us to be part
of that process, and let us
never forget that is the case.
So all of this to say still
leaves the question of language,
spoken language versus
sign language,
and that debate has been a long
standing one over the years
from Plato, you know, to
the 1880's, even to now,
people really advocating for, you
know, the use of spoken language
or the use of sign language.
Research over the last 12 years
at Gallaudet has really come
to realize it's not an
either/or proposition,
and it never has been an
either/or proposition.
It's more of an and proposition.
If you develop a bilingual
brain in a deaf child,
that child's brain will thrive as
a result, and if that child is able
to produce spoken language,
that's fine.
They can pick up English.
That's still available to them.
They can read or write English
if they can't speak English,
but having access to
a visual language
as well creates a powerful
opportunity for brain development,
and that's just extraordinary.
And so finally we have
science catching up to what we
as a community has known all along.
Science is now verifying the
fact that we have been saying
for a number of number of
years, and that fact, of course,
really is represented in the
beauty of our university,
how we can have an
immersive experience
for people of our community.
That government and our country
have allowed people in our community
to have this opportunity
is significant
because there's no other
experience like it in the world.
I want to shift a bit to talk
about the ADA and our Constitution
where it talks about the goal
to create a more perfect union.
The ADA to me is one of the
first steps in that process
in this country to create
that more perfect union.
And so I asked myself as
I prepared to come here,
what have we learned
in the past 27 years?
What have we learned?
And one of the first things that
comes to mind is that education
and learning that is really
honed in on the individual skills
of that child and the unique
approach that they bring
to the world is critical to the
success of every child in America,
whether that child has a disability,
despite their skin color,
their religious beliefs,
their political affiliations,
religious beliefs, all of those
social constructs created by people
to label, to separate, and take
people from coming together united,
without paying attention to that
person's unique way of being
and what they uniquely
bring to the world.
That is very powerful, and why
don't we teach to that strength,
that uniqueness that they bring
instead of to their weakness?
When we teach to the child's
weakness, their inability to hear,
we take away from what we can
give them, and we instead teach
to their ability to have that visual
language, and why not do both?
Why not afford them both
that opportunity to speak,
have access to that language
as well as sign language?
And ADA is an invitation
for us to engage
in that kind of a conversation.
Moving on to employment.
That's the key to a strong country.
Deaf people's success in the
United States has been afforded
by their access to
employment opportunities.
Many Gallaudet graduates go into
the workforce, and strangely enough,
in the last 10 to 15 years,
our progress in the employment
arena is not been as great
as it had been before the passage of
the ADA, and the question is raised
as to why that is the case.
What's the fundamental
problem that we need
to address in order to change that?
Minnesota and the federal government
in the past looked to the number
of people with disabilities and
saw that's over 20, 15 to 20,
30 percent of these
individuals-never 30,
but at least 15 to 20 percent
of the population is disabled.
After 2007, after the recession,
the numbers began to drop off to 2
to 7 percent of the disability
community being employed,
and this creates the
future challenge for us.
Our work is not done.
We sit back and look to the
wonder of ADA, and, yes,
certainly we do recognize that,
but we also recognize the work
that needs to be done and what
we need to do in order to change
and improve our employment
outcome for all people
with disabilities,
not just deaf people.
Learning and engagement in
the community is our right,
and that's a lesson that
we learned from the ADA.
We have a right to learn and be
engaged in the community around us,
and that's what leads to us
being strong citizens-engaged
in the political process and
our communities and our schools
and our family units, and
our deaf organizations,
and a variety of other places.
Access. If we talk about
access, it is public good.
I mean don't think it
only being about you
as an individual having access,
but it is in overall public good
and applies to every single one of
our us-- our families, our friends,
our communities around us.
Providing interpreters
and captioning is not
just advantageous
for people who are deaf.
It's advantageous for
everyone in the room.
It is about public good, and that
kind of language needs to change,
and that is the impact of the ADA.
We must choose to broaden
the understanding
of the impact of the ADA.
It provides access, and that
access is public good for all.
And lastly, as we know at Gallaudet
we have students who enter,
and often what happens to
them, they thrive tremendously
so because they can be fully engaged
in the life of the community there.
You know many of you
graduated from Gallaudet,
and I think most of
you I think have.
I think there are some who are
still working their way through
or in graduate school,
but what's interesting is,
you know we continue the search,
the search for that perfect world
that is more broad than
the one where we live.
We seek to how we can have that same
feeling of having full engagement
in the broader world
around us and not just
within a localized community.
Let us shift the conversation
away from hearing loss
to really understand a
multi-lingual community
that can thrive with us together.
Think about the Spanish
speaking families,
the Arabic speaking families,
the German speaking families,
the French speaking families, all
of them coming together with us,
thriving together in a
multi-lingual community.
How can we make that happen?
These are the questions that we have
to address over the next 27 years.
These are our thoughts and
considerations that should lead
to action and leadership
in the next 27 years.
You know, we must rely on each other
to come up with these solutions
to improve the quality of
lives for everyone post ADA.
Thank you for the invitation
to be here today
and to be part of this conversation.
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker: Thank you
very much for coming.
It's very fascinating to hear about
your contributions to the university
and to students and
about the challenges
that you see there lying for us.
Obviously you were involved
before the ADA passed,
and your perspective now
on how things have changed
and where they're going,
it was wonderful.
So thank you.
So we started this event
with Congressman Yoder
talking about legislation.
We've had Congressman Takano
talk about deaf interns
and how they are helping the
deaf communities that they serve.
We've had the President of
Gallaudet University talk to us
about deaf education and the
challenges that she's seen
in her life and those
she sees set before us,
and now I'd like to
wrap up the event.
I'd like end with something
that's-someone who has grown
up without knowing a time before
the ADA, somebody who may have been,
who was not used to the challenges
of the past and can now show us
about his love for
books and for language.
So I'd like to invite August
Kitama to the stage-Shitama,
a TEDx presenter, to join us here.
>> Shitama: Hello, everyone.
I first want to thank Dr. Hayden
for hosting this wonderful event.
I also want to thank
Representatives Yoder and Tokano
and President Cordano for guiding
the way for us to become more equal
and for a brighter future
for the deaf community.
I'm honored to be among people who
have been fighting in this fight
for the deaf community
here in this room.
Because of their persistence and
because of their passion I am able
to stand before you today.
So, you know, I have a dream to
become on the national stage.
I'm honored to be among you.
One thing that I think
that I'm honored to be here
because this is the
Library of Congress,
and I have a severe love for books.
So before I get going, I'm going
to ask the interpreter just
to silence his voice
for about 10 minutes.
I'm just joking about not
having an interpreter.
[Laughter] But let's
take a moment to reflect
about how it felt to
watch me signing.
To know what I wasn't saying-to
now know what I was saying
without the interpreter voicing
for me, how did that feel?
How did it feel to
be left in the dark?
I'm sure it was awkward, right?
And then when you finally heard
the interpreter's voice again,
I'm sure you sighed
a bit of a relief.
It was a light that sort
of went off in your head,
and that is what I
call the sort of agony
and ecstasy of the human connection.
We all want to feel a connection.
That's natural, but that connection
is not something we can always see
or hear.
It's something that we can feel.
There's something that
we feel in our heart.
It's a moment of clarity.
I discovered this when I was a
wee lad learning how to read.
Even though sign language is
how I prefer to communicate,
reading allows me to learn
more about the world.
There's a lot you can
learn about the world just
by hearing it somewhere, like on the
radio when you're driving to work,
or through the grapevine, which,
what I understand, is a polite way
of saying that you've been
shamelessly eavesdropping.
[Laughter] I don't
have that privilege
to consciously absorb information
without actively pursuing it.
That's not a burden for me.
It's actually a blessing.
What wasn't handed to me I've
wanted for myself with a passion,
and that passion started when
I was in pre-kindergarten.
We had a customary naptime,
which was never my cup of tea.
Luckily one day my teacher told me
that I didn't have
to naptime anymore.
Instead she took me into her office.
She had piles of books, vocabulary
cards, and colorful pictures
of everyday things, but I
didn't know the word for it.
I felt like the cartoon man
sketched above the word excited.
I was right there in my teacher's
office when I learned how to read.
Learning to read was
a fascinating process.
Unless you know someone who is deaf,
you've probably never considered
how an audible language can be
taught visually.
It usually takes four steps.
My teacher would show me a drawing
of a hairy beast, and then letter
by letter she spelt the
corresponding word in English
and ASL, and then showed the sign.
So I made the connection between
the written word, the paper,
a finger spelling, and
ultimately a sign, and now I knew
that hairy beast was a dog.
That was essentially the
foundation for my reading skills,
but there's one crucial
thing missing-my own voice,
and what I mean by this is I was
mechanically competent in writing,
but it was too precise, devoid
of any natural occurring humanity
that is so apparent in everyone's
voice, both spoken and written.
What I craved was to be able to
express myself as authentically
as possible through writing,
which at that point was tricky
because I couldn't hear
organic conversations
and [inaudible] that organically.
Fortunately, I discovered a book of
children's stories called "A Series
of Unfortunate Events" by Lemony
Snicket in the third grade.
It was about the Baudelaire orphans.
They lost their parents
in a terrible fire,
and now their new guardian, Count
Olaf, is a vile egomaniac who lies
to get whatever he wants, including
the orphans' enormous fortune.
Snicket's writing style
is quite distinctive,
which I would say means
easily recognizable due
to the author's affinity
for humorously defining
his large vocabulary
in the middle of the story.
For me, it was love at first word.
Here was this book written
for children that had words
like penultimate, standoffish,
words that you don't normally read,
and his tone was interesting
as well.
It was very funny and familiar.
It was something that I want.
So as I started to read
more through the series,
I had a new dimension
added to my prism.
One day I saw the world through
the eyes of a cynical New Yorker,
David Sedaris, where a horrible
incident could be recounted
as a darkly funny anecdote.
The next day I'd see the world
through Atticus Finch's eyes
as a place to never lose hope when
it comes to fighting the good fight.
Eventually my perspective
became an amalgamation
of the books I read over the years.
Reading the conversations
in these books was
where I found a natural rhythm.
That rhythm fermented from reading
the close captioning on TV shows
like "30 Rock" and "Seinfeld" with
a cascade of rapid fire word play,
and that was the humanity
I longed for in my writing.
With a solid understanding
of the art of conversation
in English, I found my voice.
Throughout this journey
I never stopped reading.
I learned to read about the world.
The value of reading comes
from the power of information.
I read to rid myself of
ignorance, and I can tell you
that when you read only 140
characters, that's not enough.
I don't want to come across as an
insufferable know-it-all but just
to show you how much I want to know.
It's when people struggle
to find meaning in life
that I find meaning in the struggle.
I have a purpose.
It's why I get out of bed every
morning lusting for novelty
where the adage goes "There's
a whole world out there waiting
for you," and I started exploring
that world by remaining in one place
with the greatest ticket
ever, a book.
In addition to falling
in love with books,
because of the strides we made in
public education and civil rights,
that disconnection
from the world I felt
as a deaf person is
no longer tangible.
To rest on our laurels and take
all our progress we've made
in the last 20 years for granted
wouldn't just be a disservice
to the trailblazers.
It would be a disservice
to our children
and our children's children.
I'm here because I know
the world is bigger
than this extraordinary nation.
I'm here because I
know we won't rest
until we leave the world a
better place than we found it,
and all of this starts with
a willingness to be a student
for life, and we can do that
just by opening a book and taking
in that first sentence
and keep reading.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>> Speaker: Thank you, August,
for your inspiring words.
I know your passion for books very
well and amazed to have you here.
Thank you to all of you who have
come to participate in this event.
I hope that you've learned
something about a new perspective
and seeing people who are deaf
signing present here at the library.
We do have events that are ongoing.
So it's nice to see a change,
to have our regular language being
replaced by American sign language.
We are finished with the event
now, but I will remind you
that we have exhibits along the side
of the room from our collections.
Everything here on the tables
is related to deaf history
in the United States, the
contributions of deaf people
across our history, and
Gallaudet University.
So you'll see some pictures,
some letters from Helen Keller,
and other such artifacts.
So if you'd like to start
looking at the chronology
of the collections we have-
>> Announcer: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.